[Music]
this year the Republican National
Convention in Cleveland overlapped with
some a comic-con here in San Diego and
yeah that you seem thrilled about that
and in honor of both conventions happy
at the same time we thought it'd be fun
to bring back someone who represents
both comic-con and the Republican Party
please welcome captain make America
great again
[Music]
[Applause]
this is incredible coded absolutely
incredible they love me they absolutely
love me they're calling me their boo
[Applause]
they're not calling you their boo they
were booing you okay okay well fine
listen listen you should be thankful
that I'm here okay I thought I knew
losers all right then I came to Cabo
all right
look at these trolls this is not an
attractive crowd something
I got this that it was really an
offensive thing that you said that was
not nice
listen coded please please this town is
an absolute toilet and it's not like a
nice toilet
[Applause]
this is a toilet clogged with Klingons
wizards and Smurfs okay now an absolute
disaster I have to tell you and they
need to put me in charge of comic card I
mean I don't know that would be a
terrible no one wants you in charge at
Comic Con that's a tradition because on
day one I will make a deal with all of
the villains the Valor mort's the
Magneto's the Joker's by the way the
Joker's a fabulous guy very nice I golf
with him you golf with the Joker he's a
homicidal maniac but I'm talking about
guns you got a bad rap true and the big
flaming eye over border I'm gonna make a
deal with that gap come on yes
absolutely it takes very very highly of
me he's retreated a lot of my stuff okay
listen he's terrible he's the
quintessence of evil whoa wait wait wait
well hold on a second I have to tell you
something else all right
Darth Vader loves me he absolutely loves
me I'm very very popular with the blacks
all four guys
and very popular went to where's my
Vader Fred where's my various areas
Isaac terrific guy there's my baby Fred
look at that he's right there I know I
gotta say you do seem to have some
influence here you know that I'd say
what I'm gonna do nice thing for you why
don't we have our security escort you
backstage to our VIP area and they'll
take really good care of you know that
is the kind of respect I deserve
plus I cannot stand being in front of
these loose
losers hail Hydra
[Laughter]
go ahead they're gonna show you out
captain make America great everyone
they're gonna show them a good time take
them outside and get them to the VIP
area that's gonna be nice very nice
they'll take them along this is
phenomenal treatment and this view is
their test
you